[Music]
just a little bit so i found this got
another knucklehead i heard about this
[ __ ] i found this and you know what
else i found
i found the camera footage
without any audio so here's what i'm
gonna do okay
i'm going to play this
audio
while
playing the video okay just so you can
kind of see what's going on for those
now so you'll know what i'm talking
about i'm talking about of course
sheriff grady john
himself the man himself the the hero of
polk county the knucklehead hunter the
knucklehead hunter
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pull up the video that he's referring to
okay here you go
play the audio first here babe she's a
pretty lady
but she was
mad
she dialed 9-1-1 and complained about
her
order at mcdonald's
her sister tried to get her out of the
mcdonald's
she wouldn't do that
instead
she continued on her rant and her rage
you know i don't know what was wrong
with her that night i don't know if she
was like two fries short of a happy meal
get it
i don't like that he's now leaning into
this yeah
or maybe it was she was short of a happy
meal completely
but she created a mcmess
and she acted like a mcnutt
come on man
too many too many puns
too many puns sheriff
[ __ ] mcmess
you okay rice this is so stupid
but you know what she ended up a
mcburglar
on the way out of
hamburglar would have been funnier
right well he probably would have gotten
sued oh
you're right
the store
after she had already announced to
everybody she was five months pregnant
she pulled her stomach her shirt up to
show everybody her stomach
and then twerked her way out of the
store
you can't make this up
this is going to be making her
another see that another mick thing
yeah you see that she really did twerk
her way out
arresting look right here
well sometimes you gotta twerk out of
the mcdonald's
florida baby five months pregnant
classy girl five months pregnant here uh
here here's a little more
hey everyone i'm josh benson and i'm
stacy scheible thank you for joining us
a pregnant lakeland woman is wanted for
criminal charges after do you know her
i don't know you know you don't know
every woman every pregnant woman in
lakeland i don't know every pregnant
twerking woman in a mcdonald's well your
tinder and bumble would say different
a 10 minute temper tantrum
and bumble sheriff brady judd says after
she became enraged with the amount of
time her order was taking she stormed
behind the counter and made a mess
justin schecker is live at that
mcdonald's in lakeland to show us video
of the outburst justin
funny if you just behind you see merch
walking by with a cigarette and a bag of
mcdonald's
what's up
josh and stacey good afternoon to you
both this major mcmeltdown happened at
okay with this man we get it frozen how
many mechs do we have so far on this
we're like seven mechs deep at least
right
around six seven yeah okay this
mcdonald's yesterday evening the suspect
has been identified as 22 year old
tianis jones let's have sheriff grady
judd explain in his own words why
deputies want to book her in the county
jail
this is going to be mick interesting
look right here eight she's a pretty
lady i'm going to go home and eat my
[ __ ] gun after this [ __ ] all these
created a mcmas
uh and she acted like mcnutt
we got those already but you know what
she ended up i was ready burglar
she didn't get her happy meal
or her sandwich
or a chocolate shake
or a sweet tea fish sandwich in a
chocolate shake sound terrible yeah that
was a terrible combo but she managed to
get herself into a lot of mc trouble and
we're not going to give her any golden
arches but we are going to give her a
pair of silver handcuffs and you can
make money
just by helping us find this lady who
went
mick crazy for no mc reason all right
with the mix
we're at 11 enough and there's one thing
that you need to understand in polk
county
we don't put up with that mcjunk
i hate it 12 i hate it
do me a favor man
you don't realize that she was being a
mcknuckle head
you don't think she was going to make
knuckleheads i would prefer
the knucklehead stuff
he really overdid it with the mick you
know but he's met crazy over here
and sheriff judd tells us mcdonald's had
to shut down last night for the cleanup
and witness interviews with deputies
coming up new at six we'll play for you
some of that angry customers call to
9-1-1 anyone can help locate tiana's
wait what no i want to hear that
it'll it'll come out it's florida
no they said they played it but coming
up later is it
they couldn't find it
nope 9-1-1 call
up there
here
they don't know how to run a
[ __ ] mcdonald's it's like okay
yeah we'll we'll dispatch some deputies
on their way it's obviously a crime
i'm not going nowhere the police will
have to get here
hunter i have been
smash your pass
no
okay
not a more of an arby's guy
no
no they said
and that's as simple as that
white people don't know how to run no
business
and that's as simple we're pretty good
at actually running businesses pretty
well
is her sister the uh the fat friend from
cobra kai with the glasses oh my god she
does look like her
[ __ ] she can't starve
is that is that a mcchicken nugget hoe
that's a good one i'm not saying mick
but it is a chicken nugget
nugget hoe
[Applause]
[Music]
she paid she put you knock knock that
out
our public education system is really
good
you know
she's barefoot in a mcdonald's that
sounds like a nightmare to me she's a
classy broadway
you manager being barefoot and pregnant
and trashing a lakeland barrier
mcdonald's isn't uh a great life to live
is that what you're trying to do did
they say where this what part of
lakeland this was
south lakeland i'm wondering
instead of you escalating
why are you talking backwards you're
doing your job
drinking turkeys
you was waiting around here for like 15
minutes
oh my god bro it's mcdonald's
who cares
this is the sort of like this is like
that hole when keeping it real goes
wrong thing where it's just
why do so many people have to
draw battle lines in the ground over
like a hamburger